help me understand something
what the hell happened with draco the
ruler because don't you guys have mutual
people involved in each of y'all
situations so where where did things go
left he don't like that we hot
yeah
when the [ __ ] was in jail though
he wanted i don't know i think it was
that was that tape he dropped in jail
some [ __ ] uh he wanted [ __ ] on there
though
i told him no
because i [ __ ] with inglewood and
that was it he was just mad at that got
out of jail papa fish grease daughter
[ __ ] gonna tuck tail
now we're here
um
i just like i'm gonna let you take a
bong hit on camera just real quick
before we this is epic it's the first
bong hit on the bootleg hit podcast by
the way i just like the fact that my man
travels with a giant bong not a small
bong just a normal you know
that's a real boy right there
so
do you think the original the original
issue was with
uchike um and then it kind of just kind
of obviously you guys are doing an album
together and
i mean [ __ ] my city i'm from inglewood
we don't get along bro as a whole you
know what i'm saying so
that's how i move already you feel me
um
he
came at him on some [ __ ] basically like
oh you just doing that because you [ __ ]
with them nice homie being loyal bro
right feel me but now we just not
[ __ ] with nothing over there
we doing our own thing and it's like
we're not paying attention to none of
them [ __ ] but they
keep hating and keep saying something
about us so it's like we got to give
them a little attention
but other than that no
how did you think what were your
thoughts when you heard the inglewear
joint i didn't give a [ __ ] but like like
like like let's say take yourself out of
it and where you're from like did you
like what'd you think of it like as a
song that [ __ ] was not tight
yeah
it could have been better yeah i thought
the beat was hard as [ __ ]
better
you know it didn't sound threatening
like
man i'm assuming no it's like you made
the song about
like type but you call the ingo weird
type from south central right you but
i'm saying it was like it was no like
direct like nothing
i'm assuming uh i'm crazier the homie
came crazy